also denkt dass er gar nichts neues
outdoor wenn du
machst dann sagt uns
gibt es schon
[Musik]
heute abend soll eine neue flash und
bossard mittelbarer und mit mehrere zum
thema minimalismus und verzicht
durchschnittlich besitzt jede und jeder
ist so sieg gestand minimale stehen
damit am besten meint das ist verzwickt
ist das war ein fehler ja
die ihr vermögen die westliche welt zum
teil aber die zarte sichergestellt dass
ich war extrem strecke die zeit kursiert
irgendwie hat das der eifersucht zu
absteiger
serviert und so weiter
was ist mit
die einzeln
das gefühl hat minister
17 und bohrung screen anziehen wenn sie
ganz dringend extremus nicht unter
sehnsucht ich meine was die absätze der
schuhe besitzt das manchmal pets tropfen
oder das handy ist kurz beispiel die
freiheit macht dies aber auch abhängig
ausgabestellen der größte macht begrüßen
dann verzichtet der
befreiungstheologie philosophie sieht
sie nichts dann wirst du nicht besessen
die idee natürlich also quasi die sache
wacker-trainer aber wenigstens habe form
vor altersarmut wirksam kite wo
natürlich habt ihr gesehen was kannst du
dich hier brennen juni in europa ksze
das ist eine emotionale
ich glaube im endeffekt sind sie oft
gebraucht gestand dass ich meine
natürlich geht es zur sache wie der
jährigen zum beispiel lockt
die
augen aber die wirtschaftlage die welt
verliehen habe ich finde gerade jetzt
viel über die friedrich hofmann thomas
flüchten und alles so klar und
der
französische schriftsteller marcel
proust die ganz berühmten
die dunkle materie und ist und die ganze
kindheit aufgrund von den geschmack und
dozent widerruft und wer hat das sagen
wenn ich irgendwie halt die hindenburg
und ist damals akzeptanz berufung ich
denke das heißt diese identität gehört
mit der eu sondern die scheite gestand
drin darum finde ich so schön die idee
ist vom minimalismus
kritisch so streng ist irgendwie an zu
wenig poetisch wer so viel gestand am
konsum gar standzeiten consumer business
realistisch aber mit konsumiere tags
einer
erlaubnis
gestellt und oft darüber was irgendwie
mit
der geruch sei
absolut richtig
schön
es gibt nur die ganze andere viele viele
sind sie also wirklich richtig
gern für
viele sachen und ich wieder brauchen
viele emotionale warten würde jetzt
behaupte bücher berechtigen einbruch
gegen die das blog für mich interessant
nicht ganz sagen dass ich mir ich bin
genau wie du was so schlag geben um die
ganze sache
tiere sind für mich die total
bestätigt
[Gelächter]
ersatzhandlung so komplex und so
unübersichtlich wurde dass man jetzt
versucht heime aufzogen und regen ist
besser für das schlimmste aber sexy tour
schön
genau was man schlicht ohne
übersichtliche weiter ab und zu
macht es einfach
die version für grundlos auf
schwierigkeiten psychologisch gut aber
ich mache es ungern aber wenn ich mache
viel zu kurz da damit reinheit du immer
schon diesen fragen
das ist körper die reihe der fehler mit
dem bedürfnis zur kontrolle gab
neue protestantismus
sagen wir wissen dass krise
hätte waschen religiöse dimension
behoben sind stiftung aber ich finde es
besser wenn der grundsatz der in der
folge kräftig nachhaltigkeit wenn man
gerade diskutieren auch in das ist eine
verständlichkeit wenig konsumiert
verschleiß ist groß aber tätig der
händler also erich fromm haben oder
scheiden wegen des klasse die haltung
dahinter dass ich
mich selbst warten nicht vor dem
aufwachen nicht besitzen sondern vor dem
was ich bin
sehr einfach ist aber für mächtig vor
der genügsamkeit versprochen bis ganz
wichtig ich bin mir aber
bewusst
machen sich abhängig definiert man sehr
viel über das oder weiß man das
historische philosophie das geschäft
in wertheim ist hartz iv und deswegen
die kinder alleine bewältigen betreff
der wichtigste punkt die achseln wichtig
und das ist die folge seit dem krieg
oder dieser abschnitt widerspricht bmw
wurde gesagt ich dass jede gestand
wieder so wahnsinnig stark und
organischen im juni nur um überhaupt
wirklich ein grafisches lebensgefühl
wurde in der kritik
es steht ja alles so
rasch des ladens kühlen charme richtig
und worum ich das aber schwierig es ist
ja gut sondern buchheim lila zu viel her
wenn minister gestand stilisiert ich
mache
also was ist glück macht
konsum vorträgen websites sondern
bezieht und erlaubnis andere kurz europa
- also irgendwie ein glücksgefühl
länderfinanzen neue dass wir einen
neuwagen geruch
hier bezogen neue jahr gestartet
das sehe gar nichts neues auto
es gibt schon lange was
gibt es neues buch
und du kommst du her stimmt und es
schlägt das buch ist doch mehr
bestehen
das ist faszination überhaupt
neugier steckt das ereignis grund nicht
bis ganz neues vor der
stimmen kommt
dann endlich zu einer neuen iphone vans
wie das neueste haben sie laut studie
ganz konsum funktioniert also die ganze
idee als spanischer produkte tatsächlich
verkürzt wird zeit noch so klar dass zu
dem letztlich doch das genau die
sehnsucht der
produkte
ist nämlich also die geplante ob so
lässt enz also die idee dass ducati
ihren drucker so macht dass er nach
einer gewissen stufe drei stufen und es
gibt zum beispiel
account kein ersatzteil da schon wieder
computer zum 1000 du hast das ist alter
ladekabel passt natürlich
nicht ich sehnsucht noch einmal unter
punkt 1 ich würde sagen er merkt
brauchbar du noch die sehnsucht
in
ihrem buch revolution die das leben von
kaputt besitzen oder etwa seit die meist
es auch gar nicht setzen die waren
kaputt machen damit
schlage umgang das duell geschlagen hat
und das kenn ich
waldemar schule
nicht bringen wir das zusammen also ist
minimalismus haben wir doch vielleicht
sage ich habe die die wenig sätze mehr
viel bedeutet und das alter wo ein
langer pass turin wo irgendwelche bis
erwarten oder wirtschaft sind sowohl
herbert module und besprechen denn
könnte so zusammen teilt hat mit
nachhaltigkeit werde die die folgsamkeit
reduktion und die befreiung oder
verzichten sie hier absolut und doch und
einer strategie und da wird und was den
eigentlichen minimalismus geht es um
minimalistische blick wald oder gar
übertreffen tag denn er hat alles unter
fast nur in schwarz und das macht es
natürlich wahnsinnig einfach wie du denn
kochen lauda und dur beschwerden city
schon um reisende vor schickt das
wirklichkeit zwischen sache
27 grad sind ideal
die schwedische auswahl aber schien
überfordert aber wenn du sieben farben
wahrscheinlich unbehagen ist ich glaube
dass heute konsum auf die und digitale
kanton ist also vor der minimalist
auf dem handy müsste die dena
minimalistisch konsumiere
zum beispiel ja du hast ein neues
quartier ihr abitur verfehlt und ich
finde
das heißt das konzept müssen wir noch
einige neue danke also mit mit messer
aber schon wieder zunahmen immersion
immer noch mit einer digitaler
weiterleitet dann müssten wir ächten die
minimalistische ideal versuchen
irgendwie jetzt aber
ich finde dass handlung steht das ist
ein merkmal minimalismus und nicht nur
lustig sondern hat produkt für europa
ist grotesk mali kontrastieren rettig
ist noch ein workshop
sich strasser der kritischen zu sehen
und doch habe ich ein produkt im stil
von minimalismus aber sicher dass
konsumiere werden statt einfach nur
wenige das und nicht befindliches hebel
frechen synagoge oder laufe und die
sache schön finde und danke so schön ich
brauche zudem hatte ich habe da sprechen
euro
angehoben wie stand er zum minimalismus
was
unglücklich
kommentaren bei der hmi zum thema
entrüstet zurück sträucher als mit dem
musiker nitsch und eis ein stammtisch
mit dem post wachstums ökonomie coupé
und ein eventuell besser abonniert kanal